bonjour à tous la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat a auditionné
cette semaine Marisol Touren la ministre
des Affaires sociales et de la Santé a
été entendu à propos de deux thèmes
d'abord sur la réforme des retraites qui
a d'ailleurs été adoptée de justesse par
l'Assemblée nationale mardi dernier
réforme qui prévoit un allongement
progressif de la durée de cotisation
pour atteindre 43 annuités pour la
génération de
1973 puis Michel delonet et Dominique
Bertinotti ont rejoint marietouren les
ministres délégués sont arrivés afin
d'être auditionné sur le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014 mais d'abord place aux
retraite et retour à cette audition qui
s'est déroulé en salle clémenenceau
mercredi madame m la
présidente madame messieurs mesdames
Messieurs les les rapporteurs mesdames
messieurs
sénateur je je vais aller assez vite sur
ou dans ma présentation du projet de loi
retraite et je m'excuse par avance les
micros sont très bienvenus je n'ai plus
beaucoup de voix mais j'espère que que
tout ira bien je je vais essayer d'aller
assez vite dans la présentation initiale
ce texte a été débattu
dans la presse je parle évidemment pas
de l'Assemblée nationale dans la presse
et donc ces grandes articulations ces
grandes orientations sont connu en
revanche vous pouvez souhaiter avoir des
réactions ou des points de précision sur
tel ou tel aspect que je n'identifierai
pas nécessairement comme prioritaire à
vos yeux pour commencer je voudrais dire
que ce projet de loi répond à un triple
défi le défi financier bien sûr puisque
euh le déficit prévisionnel en 2020 est
de 20 milliards d'euros tout régime
confondu y compris régime complémentaire
de 7 milliards et demi pour le régime
général deuxème enjeu auquel il nous
faut répondre c'est un enjeu
démographique temporaire ciblé identifié
à l'évidence nous devons faire face au
vieillissement de la population d'une
population plus nombreuse puisque c'est
celle du baby
mais dans le même temps je veux
souligner que cette démarche
démographique
ou ce critère démographique doit aussi
être appréhendé de façon positive car
contrairement à ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays la vitalité démographique
que nous connaissons nous permet de
stabiliser la situation à partir de 2035
ce qui ne veut pas dire que la situation
devienne facile ou simple nécessairement
mais cela veut dire que la dégradation
des comptes est très marqué jusqu'en
2035 et à partir de 2035
elle se stabilise le troisième enjeu de
ce texte de loi c'est de répondre à des
injustices qui existent qui se sont
constitué au fil des années qui sont
pour nous insupportables le fait que les
pensions des femmes soient largement
inférieures à celles des hommes que le
système de retraite Vienne aggraver les
inégalités issues des carrières
professionnel euh le fait injustice
concernant ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler très jeunes et qui ne sont
pas suffisamment reconnus injustice
d'imposer à ceux qui ont travaillé dans
des conditions pénibles de partir dans
les mêmes conditions
et complexité de l'entrée dans la vie
active c'est pour cela que nous avons
fait le choix d'une réforme qui est une
réforme de progrès et le progrès c'est
d'abord de garanttir
le financement dans la durée de nos
régimes ne pas s'atteler au financement
des
régimes de retraite c'est prendre le
risque d'ouvrir la porte à des
mécanismes de privatisation qui sont
toujours
tentant pour certains et ce que le
gouvernement
refuse l'effort financier à réaliser est
important je l'ai dit il est néanmoins à
notre portée et il se traduit par une
par des mesures qui s'inscrivent en deux
temps pourquoi en deux temps parce que
nous avons considéré qu'il ne fallait
pas perturber les plans de départ à la
retraite de ceux qui s'apprêtent à
quitter la vie professionnelle et qu'il
faut on sait que les gens font
établissent des projets de départ euh
quelques années avant la date prévue et
donc nous n'avons pas voulu interférer
avec cela c'est pour cela qu'il y a
une politique en deux temps avec des
mesures qui visent à consolider le
financement d'ici 2020 et une mesure de
d'allongement de la durée de cotisation
progressive à partir de 2020 d'un
trimestre tous les 3 ans inscrit dans la
loi et qui aboutira à 43 annuités de
cotisation en
2035 d'ici 2020 vous le savez nous avons
fait le choix de l'augmentation des
cotisations patron et salariale
progressive jusqu'en 2017
et une mise à contribution des retraité
par un report de la revalorisation des
retraites du 1er avril au 1er octobre
2014 ce qui est un effort réel mais
ponctuel et qui n'aura lieu qu'une fois
et par ailleurs la fiscalisation des
majorations versées au retraités par an
de trois enfants et plus sur ce point je
ne doute pas que nous aurons des
discussions ou sur ces points je ne
doute pas que nous aurons des
discussions je veux insister sur deux
principes qui nous ont guidé le premier
c'est celui d'une mise à
contribution de l'ensemble des catégorie
de notre société parce que pour nous la
retraite est un est au cœur du pacte
social c'est au cœur du pacte
républicain et sauver l'avenir de nos
retraites ça doit mobiliser l'ensemble
de la soci
c'est pour cela que nous avons demandé
que nous demandons au retraités une
contribution alors même que ils sont
déjà partis en retraite parce que cela
fait partie de la solidarité
intergénérationnelle et puis le deuxième
principe qui nous a guidé c'est que
chacun apporte sa contribution quel que
soit le régime auquel il appartient ou
dont il relève et je veux indiquer que
tous les régimes publics comme privés
régimes spéciaux comme régime général
sont concernés par les mesures que je
viens d'indiquer aussi bien les mesures
de contribution financière que
d'allongement de la durée de cotisation
le réforme de progrès
disais-je dans la mesure d'abord où il
s'agit de garantir le financement et
donc l'avenir de nos régimes de retraite
réforme de progrès ensuite car cette
réforme crée des droits nouveaux et
permet de répondre à des injustices qui
se sont constituées euh le point central
de la réforme vous le savez c'est la
mise en place d' d'un compte pénibilité
d'un compte de prévention de la
pénibilité l'enjeu c'est quoi c'est au
fond de dire que à partir du moment où
nous vivons plus longtemps on peut
accepter de travailler un peu plus
longtemps mais que nous ne pouvons pas
tous être sollicité de la même manière
car nous n'avons pas tous les mêmes
conditions de vie et les mêmes
conditions de travail et l'un des
facteurs de différenciation des
carrières professionnelles c'est
évidemment la question de la pénibilité
donc la mise en place d'un compte de
prévention à compté du 1er janvier 2015
l'année 2014 étant consacré à la
préparation de ce compte à la mise en
place des procédures ce qui demande
évidemment du temps 10 facteurs de
pénibilité ont été défini par la voie de
la négociation entre les partenaires
sociaux ils ont fait l'objet d'un accord
en 2008 ils sont inscrits dans la loi et
c'est donc ces critères-là qui serviront
de référence l'exposition à ces facteurs
ou à ces situations de pénibilité
donneront lieu donnera lieu pardon à
l'acquisition de points ces points
seront convertible en période de
formation en période de travail à temps
partiel payé rémunéré à temps complet ou
en retraite anticipée le deuxième sujet
qui est présent dans cette loi c'est la
question euh des femmes évidemment on ne
peut pas au niveau de la retraite
corriger l'ensemble des inégalités euh
accumulé pendant une carrière
professionnelle néanmoins euh nous avons
eu la volonté de ne pas les entretenir
ou de ne pas les amplifier c'est ainsi
qu'un certain nombre de mesures sont
prises je veux signaler en particulier
le fait
que désormais seront prises en compte
pour la retraite l'ensemble des périodes
d'interruption au titre de congé de
maternité ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui aussi incroyable cela
puisse-il paraître et
puis le deuxième facteur important c'est
une meilleure prise en compte du travail
à temps partiel or les femmes sont
celles qui à 80 % occupent les emplois à
temps partiel partiel et à partir donc
de l'année prochaine il faudra avoir 150
heures travailler par trimestre pour
pouvoir valider enfin he SMIC pour
valider un trimestre contre 200 he
aujourd'hui ce qui concrètement veut
dire qu'une personne une femme par
exemple qui travaille 12h par semaine
qui aujourd'hui ne peut pas en
travaillant 12h par semaine valider un
trimestre le pourra avec cette réforme
trème prise en compte 3ème injustice sur
laquelle nous répandons c'est la
situation des jeunes qui sont confrontés
à une entrée dans la vie active plus
difficile plus chaotique plus heurté
nous prenons donc un certain nombre de
mesures d'abord la prise en compte de
l'ensemble des périodes d'apprentissage
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui un
cycle d'apprentissage dans sa globalité
ça concerne environ 400000 personnes
donc en ce moment à l'heure à laquelle
nous parlons si j'ose dire il y a 400000
jeunes qui sont dans une situation
d'apprentissage euh sous une forme ou
sous une autre et dont l'ensemble des
périodes ne sont pas validé elles le
seront d'autre part nous avons mis en
place un dispositif euh de soutien au
rachat euh de trimestres correspondant à
des études post bac avec une aide
significative de l'état euh par ailleurs
nous avons dans le cadre du débat
l'Assemblée nationale permis une
meilleure prise en compte des stages
puisqu'il sera possible désormais de
valider un trimestre de stage en en
contrepartie d'une contribution de 12,50
€ par mois pendant 2 ans ce qui ou de 25
€ pendant un an ce qui est significative
4e injustice à laquelle nous répondons
dans ce texte c'est celui celle des
petites pensions avec le relèvement du
seuil de versement du minimum
contributif avec la prise en compte euh
de l'ensemble des périodes de formation
professionnelle pour atténuer les
carrières précaires ou heurté et puis
des mesures en direction euh des
agriculteurs je terminerai en indiquant
que nous avons aussi souhaité que ce
texte mette en place un dispositif qui
soit stabilisé dans la durée euh plus
simple et plus lisible stab dans la
durée cela se traduit par l'instauration
d'un système de pilotage qui sera
réalisé par un comité de suivi qui sera
chargé de faire des recommandations en
cas de dérapage soit financier soit
social de nos régimes de retraite
financiers si les déficits se creusent
par exemple social si on s'aperçoit que
la retraite des femmes évolue de manière
défavorable par rapport à celle des
hommes contrairement à ce que nous
souhaitons je prends ces C ces points à
titre d'exemple comité de pilotage qui
donc fera des recommandation au
gouvernement lequel gouvernement qui
seront rendu public mais le gouvernement
gardera la maîtrise des décisions qu'il
prendra pour faire face aux situations
identifiées volonté de
simplifier le système puisque nous
allons créer un contre-traite unique qui
sera accessible en ligne pour chaque
Français qui permettra au moment de la
liquidation euh de demander sa pension
avec une déclaration préremplie et qui
permettra après la liquidation un
paiement simplifié voilà comme vous le
savez donc ça a été dit par Annie David
tout à l'heure votre présidente le texte
a été voté hier en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale l'examen doit
commencer ici en séance publique euh le
28 euh octobre et euh c'est là un débat
dont je ne doute pas qu'il va mobiliser
les uns et les autres mais c'est
évidemment un débat important pour notre
pays pour l'avenir de notre système
social merci madame la ministre pour
cette présentation finalement complète
de de cette réforme je vais donner tout
de suite la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs donc Christian deess pour la
commission des affaires sociales merci
madame la Présidente merci madame la
ministre si vous le permettez je ne
reviendrai pas sur le fond hein de de ce
de cette réforme mais au fur et à mesure
des auditions que nous avons pu faire
tant au sein de la commission des
affaires sociales que en tant que
rapporteur sur ce projet de loi un
certain nombre de points un petit peu
plus précis euh ont attiré mon attention
et je souhaitais vous interroger madame
la ministre sur sur ces points premier
point je les donne pas forcément dans
l'ordre des articles du pro projet de
loi vous m'en vous m'en excuserez
euh euh premier point qui concerne
laagire Carco et lire
KC puisqu'il y a eu à l'Assemblée
nationale un article 33 bis dans le
texte qui a été voté à à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui
modifie de manière substantielle la
situation puisque je je développe très
rapidement aujourd'hui euh c'est le
statut de
l'établissement qui prévaut pour euh le
la prise en charge du de des cotisations
retraite aujourd'hui les établissements
privés les entreprises privé c'est l'
l'agir Carco hein pour les retraites
complémentaires pour les établissements
publics ou assimilés c'est l'ircantc euh
le texte tel qu'il a été voté à l' à
l'Assemblée nationale
change la méthode puisque c'est le
statut du contrat de travail qui
décidera de l'affiliation à l'agir Carco
ou à LIR contexte je
précise dans les établissements publique
ou dans la fonction publique il y a bien
évidemment des fonctionnaires mais il y
a aussi des contractuels qui sont en CDI
ou en CDD qui peuvent être de droit
public ou de droit privé ceux qui sont
de droit public pour l'instant tout le
monde est à l'ircantech ceux qui sont de
droit les contrats de droits public
restent à l'irconch les contrats de
droits privés seront basculés sur l'agir
Carco donc je veux savoir ce que vous en
pensez madame la ministre et en plus on
sait qu'il y en a des contractuels
aujourd'hui qui sont qui enchaînent les
CDD donc que va-t-il advenir de ceux qui
sont en CDD de droit privé et qui vont
avoir un contrat renouvelé à la fin du
CDD toujours endroit privé est-ce que
pour les CDD actuels ils resteront à
ircantc et pour les suivants ils
deviendront agercco voilà je voudrais
des précisions sur sur cette question là
deuxè deuxè type de question vous voyez
elles sont un peu techniques mais je
pense que c'est important que vous
puissiez nous répondre deuxième type de
question concernant la majorité de durée
d'assurance pour les aidant
des la qu'est-ce que j'ai dit
excusez-moi excusez-moi je commence à
fatiguer moi aussi madame la
ministre la majoration de la durée de la
durée d'assurance pour les aidents
aujourd'hui il y a une majoration qui
est
prévu et qui donne droit à à des
trimestres je rentre pas dans le détail
pour les personnes qui accompagnent un
adulte handicapé quand est-il qu'en
sera-t-il du cumul
éventuel de ce de cette majoration pour
durée d'assurance et de durée
d'assurance et surtout dans la
validation des trimestres pour quelqu'un
qui aurait accompagné malheureusement ça
peut être le cas un enfant handicapé
puis un adulte handicapé est-ce qu'il y
a cumul ou pas de cette cette valitation
pour pour trimestre euh permettant
d'être compté dans le dans le le le
système de de retraite euh 3è question
euh sur vous l'avez évoqué madame la
ministre pour sur la contribution des
retraités à l'effort euh vous avez dit
que les petites pensions seraient exempé
du passage du 1er avril au 1er octobre
hein de la du passage de la
revalorisation du du 1er avril au au 1er
octobre à quel niveau situez-vous
précisément les petites pensions euh
voilà est-ce que c'est le minimum
vieillesse est-ce que c'est le seuil de
pauvreté je voudrais que vous puissiez
nous donner des précisions et enfin
dernière question qui concerne le
système
d'information des des futurs retraités
euh tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
que le Jey infoetraite a fait un bon
travail alors quand on dit le Jey
infoetraite je reviens sur ce que disait
le directeur et le président de de la
knaf ce matin le Jey infoetraite c'est
une petite structure mais derrière il y
a un backoffice et c'est essentiellement
la knave et laag Carco qui ont travaillé
et qui ont permettez-moi l'expression
embarqué tous les autres régime pour
donner leurs informations donc le
travail a été fait on voit bien que le
nouveau Jeep
uisr marque une étape supplémentaire euh
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire comment
il est envisagé que le pass de l'un à
l'autre se fasse dans quel délai parce
que bien évidemment j'imagine que vous
n'allez pas demander à l'USR au nouveau
GIP de refaire le travail du du gipin
fetite ça serait tout à fait dommage et
mais je je sais bien que c'est ça sera
pas le cas mais comment les choses vont
s'articuler dans quel délai je pense que
c'est important aussi que les assurés
enfin les futur que les les les salariés
les futurs retraités puissent n'avoir
pas de rupture dans la chaîne
information qu'ils ont aujourd'hui et
qui a permis d'ailleurs que tout le
monde à un moment à partir de 35 ans se
pose la question de sa retraite donc
voilà voilà les les quatre questions un
peu précises que je voulais vous poser
madame la
ministre merci est-ce que je donne la
parole tout de suite à Madame la
rapporteur également pour la délégation
aux droits des femmes merci Laurence
merci n merci Madame la Ministre chers
collègues moi aussi je nous ferai grâce
de
des propos généraux sur la réforme
d'autant que je ferai moyen que Madame
la Ministre et je voudrais aborder dans
l'optique droits des femmes et retraite
des femmes une série de sujets un peu un
peu technique alors le premier concerne
la question des droits
familiaux et en particulier celle de la
majoration de 10% euh des pensions pour
les familles en élevé de trois enfants
euh ce qui a été retenu dans le projet
de loi c'est un rapport dans les 6 mois
qui suivent je crois que c'est la
promulgation de la loi maintenant après
le passage à l'Assemblée et j'ai lu dans
les travaux complémentaires que
l'objectif est de déboucher à une
réforme horizon 2020 cette horizon 2020
nous semble bien loin pour un système
qui est quand même assez défaillant et
qui en particulier aboutit en ce qui
concerne les pensions des des femmes à
quelque chose
d'assez injuste et inexplicable dans
l'hypothèse d'un couple enfin de de deux
parents ayant eu élevé trois
enfants les deux parents les deux
retraités bénéficient d'une majoration
de 10 %. bien entendu puisque c'est
proportionnel plus la pension est élevée
plus la majoration est élevé or on peut
quand même considérer que dans les cas
où les où la la la mère n'a pas
bénéficié d'une retraite à taux plein
parce que elle n'a pas elle a parce
qu'elle a pas une carrière
complète sa majoration pour avoir élevé
les trois enfants est inférieure à celle
du père or on peut admettre que si sa
pension est inférieure parce qu'elle a
eu une carrière à churé c'est justement
parce qu'elle s'est arrêtée parce
qu'elle a eu des sation d'activité qui
sont liées à son activité enfin à
ducation des enfants
et oui je veux pas dire activité de
merre pour pas qu' a l'ambiguité au fait
qu'elle a qu'elle a interrompu son
activité professionnelle pour élever les
enfants et il est quand même très
choquant que dans ce cas-là celui qui
bénéficie de la plus grosse majoration
pour avoir élevé les trois enfants c'est
le père et je me demandais si à
euh
absolument à à budget absolument
constant on ne pourrait pas imaginer que
dans l'hypothèse où la mère n'a pas pu
conduire une carrière professionnelle
complète la totalité de la majoration
lui soit versée c'estàdire qu'elle
cumule les deux
majorations ce qui rééquilibrerait quand
même l'inégalité de retraite et
l'inégalité de carrière voilà je vous
demanderai pas Madame la Ministre une
réponse à sur le champ mais je crois
quefin nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler par parce que c'est une
proposition qui se fait à budget
absolument constant et qui permettrait
d'agir en attendant 2020 qui me paraît
bien
loin ça c'est la première remarque la
deuxième
concerne la majoration pour la la
majoration pour de durée
d'assurance ma ma question est est
plutôt là sur la façon dont les parents
sont
informés dans le système nouveau pour
les enfants nés après 2004 euh les
parents de qure trimestres sont accordés
à la mère et qure trimestres sont au
choix entre les deux parents euh les
parents doivent indiquer avant que
l'enfant est atteint l'âge de 4 ans euh
à qui sont attribués les quatre la
deuxième partie des des H8 trimestres et
je voudais savoir comment les parents
sont informés de ça parce que j'ai eu
l'impression que dein
je suis pas sûr que l'information sur
cette rapidité de de choix leur soit
faite de même que on peut se poser la
question en matière d'information sur
est-ce que lorsque les femmes
travaillent à temps partiel euh les
interruptions de carrière et les
conséquences en matière de retraite que
ça engendre sont bien indiqué par les
employeurs est-ce que elle on leur donne
la possibilité au moment où
prennent des emplois temps partiel de
bien faire le lien entre le temps
partiel et la retraite partielle et la
pension partielle et là on peut
s'interroger aussi sur l'information qui
qui devrait être faite par les
directions des rources humaines à
l'égard des salariés et ça fait ma
transition vers mon trème sujet qui est
celui de la pébilité je sais que le
décret que que le
décret qui définit 41 25 215 du Code du
travail qui liste les critères de
pénibilité et le résultat d'uneion des
partenaires sociaux mais lui-même est
est adossé sur un article du code 41 21
31 qui donne le cadre législatif qui
permet ensuite la négociation et euh le
décret
euh en relisant tout ça je me suis quand
même fait la réflexion que euh il y a
des des spécificités de la pénibilité
des emploi des femmes qui ne sont pas
prises en compte par les partenaires
sociaux qu' me pardonneent ce que je
vais dire mais les partenaires sociaux
n'étant pas toujours les meilleurs
exemples de la parité dans leur
délégation dans leur
réflexion et dans leur prise en compte
de la dimension spécifique du travail
des femmes on peut pas considérer que a
priori ils ont forcément fait le tour de
tous les problèmes qui concerne le
travail des femmes et on pourrait à
l'occasion de de ce projet de loi
préciser quand même puisque le je vois
que le travail de nuit le travail en
équipe successive alternante et le
travail répétitif sont définis comme
étant des critères de pénibilité il y a
un autre type de travail qui alors
celui-là concerne essentiellement les
femme qui est le temps partiel
qui qui est le temps partiel qui laisse
des
plages horair des plages vacantes du
double du temps de travail du temps de
travail u et ce critère c'est un critère
de pénibilité réel objectif parce qu'il
induit des des des vies explosé des
temps des temps de trajets multiples et
je suggérerais que à l'occasion de la
projet loi sur les retraites on prenne
en compte la spécificité de la pénbilité
du travail à temps partiel contraint
parce que celui-là est toujours
contraint des femmes et que nous
puissions avancer dans la visibilité de
de ce qui est invisible c'estàdire la
spécificité des inégalités
professionnelles dont les femmes sont
l'objet voilà les quelques sujet merci
mesdames les rapporteurs je redonne la
parole à Madame la
Ministre
bien l que je le peux aux questions qui
ont été posées alors Christiane de
moness m'a interrogé sur l'article 33
bis qui résulte d'un amendement du
Gouvernement quel est la la la situation
et pourquoi est-ce que nous avons
présenté cet amendement donc concernant
la redéfinition des règles d'affiliation
soit agir Carco d'un côté soit à
l'IRCANTEC de l'autre parce qu'il y
avait un débat et une incertitude
juridique sur l'état du droit
incertitude qui était reconnu par les
deux régimes nous avions donc il y a
maintenant déjà plusieurs mois saisi le
Conseil d'État d'une d'un avis et et de
recomand ENF on lui avait demandé de
faire des
recommandations
juridiques le Conseil d'État a rendu cet
avis et a considéré qu'il
fallait que l'affiliation se fasse entre
la nature selon pardon la nature
juridique du contrat et non pas en
fonction
de du secteur dans lequel avait lieu
l'activité pas la nature de l'employeur
c'est d'ailleurs un principe qui nous a
aussi guidé dans la définition de la du
champ d'application du compte pénibilité
c'est exactement le même principe pour
les mêmes raisons et selon les mêmes
recommandations juridiques du même
Conseil
d'État donc l'article 30 qui est devenu
l'article 33 bis nous a permis de
clarifier cette situation et évidemment
organise une période de transition
c'est-à-dire que les affiliés actuels ce
qu'on peut les affiliés actuels ne sont
pas concernés
les pendant la période de
transition les employés vont continuer à
cotiser au régime auquel ils cotisent
aujourd'hui et après la transition il y
aura un mécanisme de réaffectation
automatique c'està-dire c'est pas les
assurés qui vont avoir à changer leur
affiliation ils vont être redirigés là
où ils doivent
être sur la question de la majoration de
durée d'assurance pour les aidants qui
en ont eu un enfant devenus adultes
handicapés quoi
concrètement oui il y aura cumul
possible aujourd'hui la majoration durée
d'assurance existe déjà pour les enfants
handicapés la loi le projet de loi que
nous présentons le prévoit pour les
adultes et il sera possible d'avoir un
cumul la troisème question portait sur
les petites pensions c'est un débat
difficile nous avons fait le choix du
minimum vieillesse donc les pensions qui
correspondent au minimum vieillesse ne
sont pas concernées par le report de la
revalorisation c'est-à-dire 787 € par
mois qui pour quelqu'un qui est
locataire aboutit à un revenu de l'ordre
de un peu plus de 1000 € puisque à ces
787 €
s'ajoute des allocations de logement de
l'ordre de 250 € par mois alors
pouvait-on avoir un autre critère et qui
aurait permis de prendre en compte un
seuil de revenu plus
élevé la réponse
est disons que les obstacles sont très
nombreux d'abord il faut un critère qui
soit identifié
juridiquement ensuite il il y a des
obstacles juridiques he à choisir par
exemple le critère du paiement ou non de
la CSG ou du taux de paiement de la CSG
là nous avons des avis
juridiques qui montrent que si on disait
par exemple les gens qui ont tel taux de
CSG ont un report et les autres n'en ont
pas on est probablement dans une
situation
d'inconstitutionnalité parce que la
CSG est un critère qui prend en compte
les revenus du couple pour la fiscalité
alors que la retraite prend en compte la
carrière professionnelle et surtout oui
c'est c'est surtout que c'est la
conception même de notre système de
retraite c'est que
c'est en fonction des droits
accumulés par la vie professionnelle
c'est un système contributif et donc
c'est en fonction de ces droits
accumulés qu'on calcule la pension donc
on ne pourrait pas faire varier des
règles relatives à la pension en
fonction de critères qui n'ont
strictement rien à voir avec la vie
professionnelle du du salarié et au-delà
de cela il y a des critères il y a des
difficultés matérielles très simple
c'est enfin très simple non si quelqu'un
a une retraite du régime général de 900
€ par exemple euh et bien on ne sait pas
si ces 900 € sont pour solde de tout
compte ou si ce sont 900 € auxquels il
faut ajouter un bout de pension euh de
la fonction publique un bout de pension
d'un autre régime c'est que nous nous ne
savons que ce que verse le régime
général et donc il peut verser 900 € à
trois personnes différentes donc nous
allons voir 900 € et à l'arrivée ces
trois personnes différentes se
trouveront dans des situations très
différentes parce que pour l'une ces 900
€ constitueront la seule pension qui lui
est versé pour l'autre il faudra y
ajouter une retraite complémentaire
classique et pour le trè ça n'est que un
morceau de de de retraite auquel
viennent s'ajouter des retraites issues
de travail de période de travail dans
d'autres régimes donc voilà la réponse
que je voulais apporter pour ce qui est
du Jeep
Info Retraite le travail effectué par ce
jeep est de très bonne qualité je le dis
c'est un travail reconnu par tous donc
il s'agit pas du tout de le contester la
mise en place d'un nouveau Jeep marque
une étape supplémentaire il va absorber
le Jeep infoetraite
d'ici juillet
2014 jusque à cette date il y aura la
préfiguration d'un nouveau Jeep qui va
englober les missions du actuel du Jeep
infoetraite et donc on va mettre en
place une mission de préfiguration qui
va permettre de basculer d'un système à
l'autre on l'espère sans difficulté mais
il y a pas de raison qui en est puisque
au fond on a le Jey Info Retraite et on
construit quelque chose de plus large
autour il s'agit pas du tout de
substituer un système à un un autreou de
supprimer ce que fait aujourd'hui le
Jeep infoetraite pour ce qui est des
droits
familiaux nous avons cherché
oui de question de Laurence
Rossignol nous
avons nous sommes partis de l'analyse
qui est que aujourd'hui 70 % des sommes
affectées ou versées au retraités au
titre des droits familiaux le sont à des
hommes pourquoi parce que que une partie
significative de ces sommes enfin disons
pour ce qui est de la des versements
monétaires c'est proportionnelle à la
pension donc puisque statistiquement les
hommes ont des salaires plus importants
que les femmes donc ils ont des
retraites plus importante que les femmes
donc ils ont une majoration de pension
plus importante que les femmes c'est
c'est purement arithmétique ça ne veut
évidemment pas dire qu'il y a plus
d'hommes qui touchent mais que comme on
verse 10 % de plus par rapport à la
retraite qui est versée comme la
retraite est plus importante 10 % de
quelque chose qui est plus important bah
10 % de 1500 c'est plus que 10 % de 750
bon donc nous nous sommes interrogés sur
la façon de réorienter ces aid soit en
direction des seules femmes c'était
d'ailleurs une des préconisations
envisagées par le rapport Morau soit en
direction des hommes et des femmes sur
une base
forfaitaire nous n'avons pas outil à un
point qui nous paraisse satisfaisant et
c'est pour cela que nous avons envisagé
ou prévu qu'un rapport devrait être
remis dans les mois qui viennent dans 6
mois pour une entrée en application 2020
alors 2020 c'est par souci de cohérence
par rapport à la date à laquelle va
entrer en vigueur l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation tout simplement avec
l'idée que quelqu'un qui part à la
retraite dans 3 4 ans il a commencé à se
dire je vais avoir une majoration de
pension pour tro enf enfant de temps et
donc ça fait partie de ses projets de
départ en retraite quelqu'un qui a une
retraite de 2000 € il sait qu'il va
avoir 200 de plus si tout d'un coup on
lui dit c'est pas 200 de plus mais
c'est X par exemple 15 € par enfant ça
fait une certaine différence donc ça
c'est l'explication de la date la
deuxième chose j'attire l'attention sur
le fait que tout
dispositif qui
vient qui s'adresse spécifiquement aux
femmes doit évidemment être très
consolidé sur le plan juridique puisque
le droit européen ne nous permet pas de
faire de différence entre les hommes et
les femmes c'est ce qui s'est passé pour
la MDA le troisième point c'est que si
on ne fait pas uniquement si on ne
flèche pas les aides ou la
revalorisation plutôt de la pension
uniquement en direction des femmes à
somme constante on aboutit à des sommes
qui sont relativement faibles et donc
qui peuvent être de l'ordre de 15 € par
enfant donc
euh voilà et à partir à condition de le
faire pour tous les enfants hein l'idée
c'est de redistribuer aujourd'hui les
aides elles vont enfin la pardon la
majoration parce que c'est pas une aide
la majoration elle va aux parents de
trois enfants donc ce sur quoi nous
avons travaillé c'est réorienter ces
majorations pour les parents dès le
premier enfant si euh on fait une
majoration forfaitaire uniquement pour
les familles non nombreus évidemment on
a une aide plus importante mais l'idée
c'était de pouvoir toucher aussi des
femmes qui ont eu un ou deux enfants
donc c'est autour de ces réflexions là
que nous devons que nous
devons travailler et et avancer pour ce
qui est euh des critères de pénibilité
l'intégration des critères de pénibilité
spécifiquement liés au travail à temps
partiel ou à des activités féminines il
a été prévu par l'Assemblée nationale un
rapport sur l'actualisation euh des
critères et il a été convenu que ce
rapport devrait faire euh ou devrait se
concentrer de manière plus particulière
sur la pénibilité des femmes et des
facteurs qui sont aujourd'hui mal pris
en compte enfin pour ce qui est de
l'information des parents sur le partage
de la MDA il n'y a pas de réponse à ce
jour puisque la situation ne se
présentera pas avant fin 2014 puisque le
choix é en fait à la fin de la 4e année
la réforme est en fait de en 2010 il n'y
a pas euh de choix à effectuer il n'y a
pas eu encore de choix à effectuer donc
aucun parent n'a été en situation d'être
informé et il appartiendra aux
différents régimes de retraite
d'informer les parents sur selon des
modalités qui restent à déterminer avant
la fin de l'année 2014 mais encore une
fois aucun parent aujourd'hui n'a été
laésé puisque aucun parent n'est
vraiment mis en situation de faire ce
choix
très bien merci pour cette première
série de réponses je vais donc donner la
parole à l'ensemble des sénatrices et
sénateur et j'ai déjà Renand Kerdraon et
ensuite Dominique vatrin ensuite GIS
prince merci madame la Présidente merci
madame la ministre je crois que je vais
essayer d'être très concis dans ce que
je vais dire je crois que nous
partageons tous en tout cas ici une
conviction c'était que cette réforme
était particulièrement nécessaire du
fait de l'échec de la réforme précédente
de 2010 laquelle n'avait pas répondu au
triple défi que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure et donc je voudrais profiter de
cette occasion pour saluer effectivement
le courage du gouvernement pour définir
enfin une réforme soutenable et durable
alors j'ai entendu également les
réponses que vous avez apporté aux
différents rapporteur qui vont
effectivement aussi dans le sens de ce
que je viens de de déclarer mais je
voudrais vous interroger sur deux deux
éléments le premier c'est l'allocation
équivalent
retraite avec Martial Bourquin et Alain
nry nous avions rencontré nous avions
rencontré en fin d'année dernière le
cabinet du Premier ministre sur ce sur
le rétablissement de cette allocation
équivalent retraite le Premier ministre
avait annoncé au mois de janvier qu'il
avoir une qu'il y avait un
rétablissement partiel de cette
allocation équivalent retraite ce qui
est très satisfaisant et et une vraie
avancée sous forme d'une allocation
transitoire si je ne m'abuse or il
apparaît que
certains bénéficiaires potentiels des
générations 52
53 qui remplissent les critères ne
peuvent pas avoir accès à cette
allocation de transition donc qu'est-ce
que le gouvernement peut faire
éventuellement pour faire en sorte que
les choses évoluent de manière positive
ensuite je voudrais vous interroger sur
également les les critères de prise en
compte des stages des étudiants là
encore c'est une excellente décision
mais est-ce que vous pourriez expliciter
davantage ces ces critères et j'ai juste
un regret à formuler c'est effectivement
qu'on n pas pu trouver des arguments
juridiques pour
rehausser le niveau et le seuil de prise
en compte pour les pensions les petites
pensions ça c'est un regret personnel
que que j'ai voilà
merci Monsieur
vatrin oui enfin moi je j'exprimerai
peut-être un autre son de cloche mais
bon on est là aussi pour émettre des
avis différents quand c'est nécessaire
moi je me suis dit si on arrive pas à la
même conclusion madame la ministre c'est
peut-être tout simplement parce qu'on
part pas de du même postulat de départ
et effectivement on me dit si si si le
point de départ c'est de dire que 2
tiers des gains de l'espérance de vie
doivent aller au travail et un/ers
seulement à la retraite c'est certain
qu'on abouti à une augmentation de la
durée des cotisations et suite aux
réformes précédentes et qui se cumule un
âge effectif de retraite qui nous est
ici programmé pour les générations
actuelles à 66 ans et je crois que vous
n'avez pas démenti cette
information je crois que pour beaucoup
d'assurés sociaux bah tout simplement
ils partiront avant parce qu'ils seront
évincés du monde du travail mais avec
des des effets de décotte et donc des
pensions à moindri ça sera le la
première conséquence concrète alors moi
je veux simplement attirer votre
attention parce que si l'espérance de
vie si c'est bien ça le postulat de
départ
euh a augmenté c'est vrai dans les
dernières années rien ne dit que
l'espérance de vie va continuer à
augmenter à l'avenir d'ailleurs ce que
l'on se rend compte c'est que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé depuis
la crise de 2008-2009 a commencé à
régresser donc la la vraie question
quant au fond et qui nous euh oppose en
quelque sorte c'est euh quel projet de
vie pour les les plus de 60 ans et je
crois que il faut quand même rappeler de
temps en temps que la la retraite peut
être un nouveau départ dans la vie
libéré de la charge de travail et utile
à la société puisqu'on a toujours
l'intent l'impression qu'on présente les
retraités comme étant une charge pour la
société je crois qu'il faut faire
attention à ça et puis bien sûr vous
mettez euh dans vos propositions
l'accent sur le déficit financier des
régimes c'est un fait mais je partage
pas le le fait de de mettre en lumière
surtout le ratio actif par rapport au
retraités parce que c'est quand même
oublié les les gains de productivité
immensees qui ont été effectué donc si
vous voulez l'actif aujourd'hui ne
produit pas du tout la même chose qu'il
y a 20 ans ou 30 ans ou et encore plus
il y a 40 ans et je crois que ça pose la
question du du manque de cotisant et il
faut quand même à chaque fois rappeler
que 100000 emplois c'est 1,3 milliards
d'euros de plus dans les caisses de
retraite et enfin je pense qu'il faut
aussi régler le problème de la
répartition des richesses mais ils
auront ce débat en séance alors pour
aller vite s'il y a effectivement
quelques avancées je crois que beaucoup
ont plus appuyé sur ces avancées qui
existe dans ce texte je crois qu'elle ne
modifie pas les lignes fondamentales du
projet et ce que vous appeler les
mesures de de de consolidation euh mais
je crois que il faut que
aussi sentir cette grande déception euh
qui existe aujourd'hui chez les jeunes
d'ailleurs qui se sont mobilisés qui
interpelle et je voulais savoir
notamment par rapport aux années
d'études bon les stages il y a une
avancé
importante mais sur les études le fait
de proposer au au aux personnes de
racheter les
études ça n'est pas satisfaisant c'est
quand même quelque chose qui qui devrait
nous interpeller je voudrais savoir si
vous avez des réponses à par rapport à
ça merci Giselle prince moi j'aurais une
petite question d'ordre pratique alors
j'aimerais savoir si l'état de grossesse
est pris en compte pour la
pébilité voilà c'est tout
très bien clirely scampion
oui madame la ministre je
voudrais consacrer mes propos aux
personnes en
situation de handicap et à leurs proches
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues
clairely scampion a la parole et
peut la voir toute seule ce serait bien
merci madame la Présidente je voulais je
disais que je voulais consacrer mes mes
quelques propos à ce qui concerne les
personnes en situation de handicap et
leurs proches en relevant tout d'abord
les mesures très positives qui sont nous
sont proposer vis-à-vis des aidants de
ceux qui consacrent et qui décident de
consacrer leur temps et une partie de
leur vie à leurs proches en situation de
handicap qu'il soient les enfants que
nous avons évoqué tout à l'heure
ou ou les adulte de la famille et qui
mesures qui permettent de de mieux
compenser les interruptions de carrière
qui
qui les concerne je voudrais également
évoquer la question du bénéfice de la
retraite anticipée des travailleurs
handicapés pour saluer les améliorations
qui sont apportées par l'article 23 du
projet de loi que vous nous proposez
madame la ministre remplaçant les deux
critères qui existent que sont le taux
d'incapacité à 80 % ou la fameuse RQTH
la reconnaissance de la qualité de
travailleurs handicapés par le critère
d'un taux d'incapacité à 50 % et en même
temps salueer aussi l'amendement tel
qu'il a été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
retardant la suppression du critère RQTH
au 31 décembre 2015 ceci àin de ne pas
pénaliser ceux les personnes qui qui ont
fait les démarches déjà nécessaires pour
prendre leur trê et qui de de ce fait se
serait retrouver laésé au moment de
partir et avec également euh deux
questions qu'en est-il des travailleurs
qui n'ont pas
demandé l'attribution d'un taux
d'incapacité en temps utile et qui de ce
fait ne sont pas en capacité de prouver
un taux d'incapacité à 50 % est-ce que
vous pouvez nous apporter des éléments
de réponse et notamment peut-être une
ouverture vers d'autres modes de preuve
de de ce dos d'incapacité à 50 %. et une
autre question attirant votre attention
sur la condition de durée de cotisation
en tant que travailleur handicapé qui
parfois peut pénaliser des personnes
soit qui souffrent d'un handicap lourd
qui apparaît tardivement dans leur
vie ou d'un handicap qui se dégrade et
qui s'amplifie en lien avec l'avancée en
âge et qui ne peuvent donc bénéficier
d'une retraite anticipée du fait de de
ne pas entrer dans les conditions de
durée de cotisation il me semble que sur
ce point il serait nécessaire qu'il soit
pris en compte et que nous puissions
apporter des réponses à ces situations
qui qui ne sont pas comprises j'ai
encore rencontré cet après-midi une
personne non voyante qui a été touchée
par la cécité à l'âge de 40 ans et qui
me disait ne pas pouvoir faire valoir
les droits à cotisation qu'il a pu
accumuler avant d'être touché par le
handicap et à et en parallèle de ne pas
être en capacité d'apporter un taux
d'incapacité à 50 % sur la durée en
question voilà à titre d'exemple très
précis merci Madame la Ministre merci
Madame Campion je n'ai plus d'autrre
inscrit donc je vais redonner la parole
à Madame la Ministre
bien là encore des questions de nature
assez
différentes le le le problème que Ren
cardraon a évoqué sur l'ATS et les qui
semble exister pour certaines
générations ont amené à l'Assemblée
nationale le vote d'un rapport qui sera
remis dans les 3 mois donc dans un délai
très rapproché pour 3 mois après la
promulgation de la
loi qui doit nous permettre d'identifier
le nombre de personnes concernées les
raisons pour lesquelles Laats ne leurit
pas versé et sur la base de ce rapport
des
décisions utiles enfin les décisions
utiles seront seront prises euh pour ce
qui
euh pour ce qui est
de des observations parce que c'était
pas vraiment une question euh de
Dominique vatrin euh oui nous avons une
approche différent
oui c'est vrai euh et c'est vrai que euh
nous ne pensons pas que l'intégralité du
temps de vie
gagné puisse être
aujourd'hui je ne porte pas de jugement
de valeur hein dans
mon mais puisse
être intégralement
euh dédié à la à la
retraite je veux signaler que compte
tenu de l'allongement de l'espérance de
vie un jeune qui aujourd'hui a 25 ans et
qui fera ses 43 annuités en admettant
qu'il est 43 annuités à faire je vais
venir sur ce point vivra 2 ans de plus à
la
retraite que celui qui part à la
retraite l'année prochaine c'est-à-dire
que malgré si j'ose dire l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation l'allongement
d'espérance de vie est
telle que il pourra vivre plus longtemps
en période de non travail que son
grand-père disons pour ou sa grand-mère
pour faire vite oui mais avec
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
donc on ne peut pas dire que
l'allongement de la durée de de de de
Vienne absorber tout le temps de de de
vie gagné l'espérance de vie elle est à
peu près bien identifié si dans 10 ans
dans 20 ans on s'aperçoit que
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie
n'est plus en rendez-vous nos
successeurs aviseront mais aujourd'hui
elle est quand même très considérable
elle représente à à so 100 ans un an
tous les 10 ans à la naissance 2 ans et
demi pour une période de 10 ans et pour
ce qui est de l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé il y a des études
extrêmement diverses c'est pas moi qui
le dis je prends je fais référence à un
auteur qui est en général bien considéré
par l'ensemble de ceux qui s'intéressent
à ces questions Serge volkof Serge
volkof dit l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé en gros euh elle est elle se
stabilise parce qu'on a des étude elle
ne se dégrade pas elle ne s'est pas
forcément amélioré des études qui
montrent que en réalité ça dépend des
métiers ça dépend des situations ça
dépend de l'âge et donc lui parle de
relative stabilisation dire que nous
pourrions régler le problème en prenant
en compte la
productivité du travail n'est pas juste
je me permets de vous rappeler que dans
les hypothèses qui figurent dans notre
loi il y a la une hypothèse de
productivité c'estd que nous pe nous
prenons évidemment en compte la question
de la productivité mais cette
productivité ne permet pas de compenser
la
dégradation du ratio démographique tel
qu'il existe aujourd'hui de même que
nous prenons en compte des
hypothèses sur le marché du travail sur
le chômage et c'est dans ce cadre là et
en fonction de ces hypothèses là que
nous faisons nos propositions si vous
prenez des hypothèses où le taux de
chômage est encore plus bas et pourtant
nous avons des hypothèses plutôt
volontaristes du même de voilà vous
pouvez vous dire si le chômage est
encore plus bas et bien on aura moins de
chemins à parcourir mais c'est donc dans
un cadre d'hypothèses économique qui
sont tout à fait formulé et tout à fait
identifié dans le projet de loi
euh c'est cette histoire de 66 ans faut
très bien d'ù elle vient mais c'est pas
en répétant à l'Assemblée et ici que
j'ai validé le fait qu'on allait partir
à 66 ans que ça devient une
vérité je n'ai jamais dit cela et ça
n'est pas une vérité la vérité et la
seule vérité c'est que la règle de
référence c'est 43 annuités de
cotisation que cette durée de cotisation
elle sera modulée en des parcours
professionnels et des parcours de vie
donc il y a des gens qui on vont avoir
des conditions de travail satisfaisantes
qui vont faire 43 annuités parmi les
jeunes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail ou qui sont sur le marché du
travail oui il y en a qui vont
travailler 43 ans c'est vrai et il y en
a qui ne travailleront pas 43 ans parce
que la pébilité ça va permettre à des
gens de partir jusqu'à 2 ans plus tôt ça
va permettre à des femmes en moyenne la
mesure sur le temps partiel sur le
travail sur l'abaissement du plafond du
nombre d'heur SMIC ça l'air très
théorique ça va en moyenne permettre à
combien ça 15 % des assurés 15 % des
assurés de gagner en moyenne 5 trimestre
de validation donc c'est pas un petit
truc la prise en compte du travail à
temps partiel c'est une mesure très
significative et donc ce que nous disons
c'est que quelqu'un vous pouvez vous
dire vous pouvez dire 66 ans en disant s
commence à travailler à 23 ans moi je
vais vous dire s'il commence à
travailler à
18 ça fait 61
et comme il aura les carrières longues
il pourra bon on peut toujours faire
toutes les hypothèses voulues mais un
peu de bonne foi ne nuit pas alors par
ailleurs pour ce qui
est des questions de
gisellece
non grossesse n'est pas
pbilité la pénibilité les critères de
pénibilité ce sont des critères
extérieurs auquel on est
exposé et la grossesse est une période
particulière de la vie qui peut amener
d'ailleurs à demander des
aménagements dans la vie professionnelle
hein c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
réalité mais ça n'est pas ça ne fait pas
partie des 10 critères qui
sont extérieurs et qui ont été
identifiés pour ce qui est du
handicap un rapport donc les questions
de clirely Campion qui sont assez
précises il y a un rapport qui est prévu
sur le lien entre handicap et travail
qui traitera des questions justement
liées en particulier lié à la survenance
d'un handicap en cours de carrière
professionnelle parce que c'est un des
sujets qui a été tout à fait fait
identifi
euh et
euh pour ce qui est du taux
d'incapacité à 50 % ça fait partie les
enfin la façon dont on pourra démontrer
qu'on est concerné ça va être déterminé
dans le décret d'application qui sera
pris en application de l'article de loi
donc des discussions des concertations
vont avoir lieu pour qu'on puisse se
mettre d'accord sur la bonne manière de
montrer que on a été confronté à un taux
d'incapacité de 50
% merci madame la ministre il me semble
que ronant cardran avait posé une
question sur les stages étudiant par
alors les stages pardon les stages
l'idée c'était quoi c'est de dire pas de
banalisation des périodes de
stage ce qui veut dire qu'on ne peut pas
accepter de traiter les périodes de
stage comme une période de travail
normale entre guillemets ce qui nous a
amené à écter l'idée de la cotisation
sur l'indemnité de stage perçu 436 €.
deuxièmement deuxième principe nous
avons considéré qu'on ne pouvait pas euh
ça me permet d'ailleurs de répondre à la
question des études qui avaient aussi
été posé par Dominique
vatrin pas de validation gratuite parce
que il y a pas de raison qu'il a une
validation gratuite alors que au même
âge il y a des jeunes qui sont déjà en
activité professionnelle et qui ctisent
et
et pour leur retraite donc nous nous
sommes arrivés à l'idée d'une
contribution pour deux trimestres de
stage appr prendre sur les quatre
trimestres d'étude supérieur
éventuellement aider ce qui veut dire
qu'il y a qure trimestres au total
d'études au titre des études qui peuvent
bénéficier d'une d'une aide c'est pas un
rachat sur les stages alors parce que un
stage au fond on demande pas avoir le
diplôme on a fait un stage d'accord on a
fait un stage on est en première année
en 2è année ou on fait un stage qui
donne lieu à gratification donc 2 mois
au
moins on bah on dit qu'on a envie de
contribuer on contribue dans une période
donnée on voit la cave et on verse 12,50
€ par an par mois ou 25 € par mois sur
un an ou sur 2 ans et on a un trimestre
validé deux trimestres peuvent être
validés comme cela pour ce qui est du
rachat donc il y a quatre trimestres
possibles ça peut donner des gens qui
peuvent racheter quatre trimestres
certains peuvent se dire j'ai fait des
stages donc je prends deux trimestres de
stage et puis d'autres peuvent se dire
bah je prends deux trimestres de stage
et deux trimestres au titre des études
d'accord c'est qure trimestres au total
avec un mécanisme d'aide qui n'est pas
de même nature pour ce qui est des
périodes d'études en gros nous prenons
en consid ration le fait que les études
contribuent à la formation mais là
encore nous ne pouvons pas admettre
l'idée d'une d'un d'une validation
gratuite et donc nous avons mis en place
un système d'aide en gros un jeune qui a
25 ans ou qui a 23 ans puisque vous
aimez l'âge de 23 ans un jeune de 23 ans
qui a une rémunération de 1250 € dans
son travail mais c'est 1250 ça peut être
le SMIC un peu 1500 bon euh il
aujourd'hui s'il veut racheter ça lui
coûte 1650 € de mémoire et avec l'aide
de 1000 € ça ne coûte plus que 650 €
donc il a un trimestre
euh validé pour 650 € euh ce qui n'est
quand même
pas inintéressant
voilà merci pour ces précisions je crois
que l'ensemble des questions a été euh
abordé
sur la retraite Laurence Rossignol n'est
pas si c'est bon c'était sur quoi
Laurence que vous vouliez d'autres
précision non non mais faudra qu'on
revienne sur cette cette affaire de de
10 % de
majoration des pères des pères oui oui
parce que c'est pas en faveur des
pères sur 10% de majoration en faveur
des parents y compris les
paires et je je j'ai bien entendu les
réponses qui avaient été faites mais
juste on a un peu de temps parce qu'on a
vous attendez les les ministes délégés
j'imagine non tu t'en
vas mais si on prend un couple dans
lequel le P le le père a une pension
égale à la moyenne des pensions pour
homme c'està dire 1600 €. il a 160 € de
majoration la mère a la moyenne des
pensions des femmes 932 € ce qui fait 93
€ on se fait grâce des 20 centimes le
total des majorations per perçu par la
famille est de 253 € ok il serait quand
même beaucoup plus juste et ça ne ferait
ça ne changerait rien euh en terme
d'équilibre du des régimes de retraite
que ces 253 € soient versés à la mer ce
qui a quelquintérêt et oui et so versé à
la mer dans la mesure dans la
mesure à condition qu'elle n'ait pas une
pension à taux plein à condition qu'elle
n''est pas une pension à taux plein
c'est la condition s ont de pension à
tau plein il y a pas
mais ça pens que soit versé à la mer
d'autant plus que quand les couples
vivent ensemble et font budget commun
c'est parfait si on peut dire mais
d'abord il y a des couples qui vivent
ensemble mais qui font pas budget commun
et il y a des tas de couples de plus en
plus de couples qui ne vivent pas
ensemble et et voilà sé
oui pas ensemble pour plein entre autres
parce qu'ils sont séparés et il serait
quand même nettement plus juste
d'attribuer cette cette majoration
totalement à la maire et je me demande
si on et j'entends bien l'argument qui a
été employé par la ministre c'estd que
il y a une cohérence avec 2020 mais
c'est des sujets qui sont totalement
indépendants les uns des autres entre ce
qu'on ce qui se passera en 2020 et cette
affaire- là il y a une indépendance
totale et pourquoi attendre pour réparer
les injustices je reviens sur sur ce
point qui est important pourquoi
attendre 2020 aujourd'hui un homme ou
une femme qui a eu TR enfant qui part à
la retraite en
2016 ou en 2018 ENF peu importe
on lui il demande quel va être son
niveau de retraite son niveau de pension
il s'adresse à sa caisse de retraite et
on lui dit madame Monsieur Votre
retraite elle est de
temps vous avez combien d'enfants vous
avez trois enfants vous aurez une
majoration de 10 % donc votre retraite
complète sera de temps si aujourd'hui on
dit que entre en vigueur un mécanisme
tout de suite différent
qui ont prévu qui vont partir à la
retraite dans quelques années avec un
montant x vont se retrouver avec X Mo
quelque chose potentiellement c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que nous ne pouvons pas j'insiste sur ce
point là nous ne pouvons pas établir de
critères différents entre les hommes et
les femmes sauf à les reli à la
maternité donc
dire ça vaique aux femmes si elles n'ont
pas de carrière complète il faudrait
évidemment que ça veuille dire que la
majoration va aux hommes en cas de
carrière non complète ce qui mais à ce
moment-là si l'homme n'a pas de carrière
complète et que la femme n'a pas de
carrière complète comment ça se passe je
dire les choses ne sont pas réglé pour
autant et par ailleurs j'ajoute que y
compris lorsqu'une femme a une carrière
complète elle peut avoir été pénalisée
parce qu'elle a choisi un métier moins
prenant parce que elle a pu travailler à
temps partiel et le travail à temps
partiel n'a rien à voir avec le fait
d'avoir une carrière complète ou pas euh
pour pouvoir s'occuper des enfants et
donc elle se retrouverait pénalisé donc
le critère de la carrière complète ne
paraît pas être un critère qui réponde
aux situations il y a un premier choix à
faire qui est de savoir si les avantages
familiaux doivent aller aux seules
femmes ou aux hommes et aux femmes si on
dit les seules femmes à quelles
condition est-ce que c'est juridiquement
possible deuxièmement est-ce qu'on veut
continuer à pr à favoriser les familles
de plus de trois enfants ou est-ce qu'on
veut valoriser les enfants dès le
premier la réponse quand même qu'apporte
la plupart des gens qui ont été
consultés sur ce point-là c'est que la
solution résiderait dans une aide
forfaitaire par enfant à quel niveau
est-ce que doit être situé cette aide
forfaitaire si on est si on raésonne à
enveloppe constante puisque la position
du Gouvernement sur ce terrain-là a été
de dire que la réforme des droits
familiaux se faisait à enveloppe
constante c'est-à-dire
que on ne venait pas
modifier ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre
les sommes qui vont à la majoration des
pensions versées aujourd'hui au retraité
par an de plusieurs
enfants merci alors Catherine procasscia
Giselle prince rapidement très
rapidement simplement pour aller pour
une fois dans le sens de la ministre
puisque sur les débats sur la majoration
des enfants quand il y a eu le quand il
y a eu le texte et l'obligation on a ce
type de débat on l'a eu mais c'était
juridiquement impossible et
effectivement la seule solution qui a
été trouvée à l'époque par le ministre
était de dire il y a qu trimestres parce
que pour cause de maternité et les
quatre autres trimestres les parents se
les répartiront et par contre je reviens
sur ce qui a été dit on avait bien dans
les débats prévu une information
spécifique alors elle est pas encore en
place parce que effectivement c'est en
2014 mais on on est quand même à la
veille de 2014 et l'information
spécifique je suis sûr qu'on l'a prévu
et qu'on a eu des amendements sur cette
sur cette information spécifique comme
on a eu d'autres amendements pour que ça
n'aille pas au père si c'était jamais
occupé des enfants Gisel
prince donc en cas de divorce par
exemple c'est la femme qui aura le si si
c'est elle qui a la garde des enfants
c'est elle qui aura la majoration de 10
%.
oui
normalement il y a plus de garde surtout
pour une femme mais parce que pour un
homme c'est plus compliqué que ça mais
pour une femme statistiquement quand
elle part en retraite elle a plus de
garde
d'enfant 10%
ou la femme aussi attention la
majoration de pension aujourd'hui elle
est versée à chaque à chaque personne
homme ou femme père et mère de plus de
TR enfants donc dans un couple comme si
un couple euh a eu trois enfants
euh s'il est ensemble ben le père et la
mère auront une majoration de pension
trois enfants sil se sépare par exemple
et que il y en a un qui reste avec deux
enfants et puis l'autre qui refait voilà
et à un troè enfant bah là évidemment il
y en a un qui a la majoration pour trois
enfants et l'autre qui ne l'a pas mais
mais parce que parce que tout simplement
il y en a qui un qui a deux enfants et
l'autre qui en a tro
mais mais c'est pas quelque chose il y a
pas de choix hein on ne demande pas de
choisir le choix il a lieu pour la la
durée d'assurance pour la MDA pas
pareil pas pour la
majoration très bien je crois que voilà
on va en rester là peut-être sur la
première partie de cette audition et
est-ce que madame la ministre vous
voulez quelques minutes ou est-ce qu'on
enchaîne sur le PLFSS on enchaîne tout
de suite très bien alors on va dès à
présent entendre madame la ministre sur
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale je vous disais que deux
ministres donc nous rejoindront madame
Bertinotti et Madame delonet et j'ai
oubliais de vous préciser que Madame
Carlotti ne pouvait être là cet
après-midi nous la verrons la semaine
prochaine nous devions voir avec elle sa
présentation sur euh le comité
interministériel du handicap donc elle
viendra nous présenter ce ce ce sujet la
semaine prochaine et peut-être que nous
pourrons aussi aborder avec elle le
PLFSS donc je vous laisse la parole
madame la
ministre très bien alors là là encore je
je vais essayer
d'être rapide pour que nous puissions
avoir des développements à partir de
questions ça a montré que c'était
finalement plus plus
intéressant le premier point que je veux
souligner c'est que les comptes
sociaux sont en situation d'amélioration
et de
rétablissement lorsque nous sommes
arrivés aux responsabilité le déficit de
la sécurité sociale et du régime et du
fond solidarité vieillesse était de 21
milliards
d'euros nous l'avons ramené à 17
milliards et demi en 2012 16 milliards
en 2013 et nous visons 12 milillards 8
en
2014 je veux rappeler que face à cela
nous avons entre 2002 et 2012 un déficit
social cumulé régime général et fond de
solidarité vieillesse de 160 milliards
d'euros ce qui est une situation qui
évidemment pèse parce que ce déficit
cumulé il
est il fait partie de la dette sociale
la loi de
financement de la séc le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité
sociale doit donc nous amener à
consolider cet effort je l'ai dit 12
milliards 8 ce qui se traduit par des
politiques de fond structurel politique
structurell en matière de retraite sur
laquelle je ne reviens pas mais je n'ai
pas besoin d'expliquer enfin on y
reviendra sans doute en séance mais j'ai
j' imagine qu'il est clair pour tout le
monde que la loi retraite a un impact
sur les comptes sociaux dès 2014 et que
donc la branche vieillesse de la
sécurité sociale s'améliorera grâce aux
mesur que nous prenons dans le cadre de
la loi retraite pour ce qui est de la
branche famille Dominique Bertinotti
pourra apporter des
éclairages plus précis ou en tout cas
répondra à vos questions mais cette loi
de financement de la ce projet de loi
décidément de la financement de la
sécurité sociale va permettre la mise en
place la mise en œuvre des mesures qui
ont été annoncées en juin dernier
l'abaissement du plafond du cootient
familial ne figure pas dans le PLFSS
mais dans le projet de loi de finances
en revanche les mesures qui ont été
prises à la fois pour soutenir des
familles modestes et pour financer des
places de crèche sont budgeté dans le
cadre de ce PLFSS je vous rappelle que
ont été annoncé la création de 275000
places d'accueil pour les enfants de
moins de 3 ans dont 100000 places de
crèche et par
ailleurs la modulation de la prestation
d'accueuil du jeune enfant la
revalorisation du complément familial
pour les ménage modeste et
l'uniformisation du montant du
complément de libre choix
d'activité donc nous avons là une
branche famille qui va vers le
rééquilibrage à partir des mesures qui
ont été qui ont fait l'objet de débat
public avant l'été mais qui se concréti
législativement parlant dans ce texte
pour ce qui est de l'ONDAM médico-social
donc nous arrivons ensuite à la
branche disons à l'aspect santé au sens
large c'est-à-dire santé médico-sociale
euh nous sommes nous nous nous engageons
dans le cadre d'une réforme volontariste
je veux insister sur le fait que des
économies importantes ont été réalisées
en matière de santé l'année dernière
nous avions prévu de milliards et demi
d'économie nous
avons dépensé par ailleurs 500 millions
de moins que ce qui avait été prévu et
ce malgré un contexte sanitaire tendu du
en raison d'une grippe de forte
intensité au début de l'année qui a pesé
euh sur les comptes de l'Assurance
Maladie nous étions l'année dernière un
objectif de dépense en matière de santé
de 2,7 %. nous euh inscrivons un
objectif de dépense de 2,4 % ce qui est
extrêmement volontariste 2,4 % euh qui
euh se décompose en 2,4 % euh pour la
médecine de ville 2,3 % pour l'hôpital 3
% pour le Médico-Social avec des aides
complémentaires qui revient à 3,4 % et
puis à la suite de la consultation de
votre commission ainsi que la commission
des affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nous avons décidé de créer un nouvel
sous un nouveau sous-objectif le fond
d'intervention régionale qui doit
permettre de répondre à des situations
locales identifiées en particulier en
matière de santé publique et qui qui lui
aura une augmentation donc de 2,4 %.
pour ce qui est donc de secteur médicaux
social un effort sans précédent a été
réalisé dès l'année dernière pour les
personnes âgées et handicapées pour ce
qui est des personnes handicapées nous
prévoyons dans le cadre de ce de ces
dépenses de financer la première annuité
du Plan Autisme qui a été annoncé en
avril dernier pour ce qui est des
personnes âgées 130 million d'euros de
crédit supplémentairire pour la
médicalisation des épas des maisons de
retraite sont prévu et au-delà vous le
savez le Premier ministre a annoncé
qu'une loi d'orientation et de
programmation pour adapter notre société
au vieillissement de la population
serait votée en 2014 elle fera l'objet
de concertation dès le mois de novembre
qui vient avec les conseils généraux et
les associations en particulier
d'établissements concernés cette loi
d'orientation débouchera sur une une
politique en deux temps le premier temps
avec la mise en place de mesures dès le
1er janvier 2015 qui concerneront la
prévention de la perte d'autonomie
l'adaptation et
l'aménagement de l'environnement des
personnes vieillissantes et
l'amélioration de l'accompagnement des
personnes perdant leur autonomie à
domicile et le deuxème la deuxème étape
de la loi et du plan concernera
l'amélioration de l'accompagnement des
personnes en perte d'autonomie en
établissement pour ce qui est de la
santé au sens strict un certain nombre
de priorités sont affichées j'ai eu
l'occasion d'annoncer il y a quelques
semaines une stratégie nationale de
santé qui repose sur trois piliers la
prévention ce que j'ai appelé la
révolution du premier recours et la mise
en place d'une nouvelle étape de
démocratie sanitaire c'est trois piliers
se retrouvent dans le projet de loi de
financement de la
Sécurité social avec la volonté de mieux
valoriser le travail des équipes de
santé
pluridisciplinaire de reconnaître la
place du médecin traitant très
concrètement cela se fait à travers des
nouveaux modes de rémunération qui
concerneront un nombre accru des équipe
dans le même temps
euh cette stratégie nationale de santé a
pour ambition de mieux accompagner de
mieux prendre en charge les personnes
vieillissantes et les personnes
atteintes de maladies chroniques
c'est-à-dire des personnes qui souffrent
souvent dans la durée ou de
polypathologie en gros nous avons un
système de santé qui est très performant
pour ce qui est de la prise en charge
des maladies aigues nous devons faire en
sorte de mieux l' adapter à la prise en
charge de personnes qui vont être
durablement malades très concrètement
nous vivons aujourd'hui avec des maladie
dont on mourrait il y a une dizaine ou
une quinzaine ou une vingtaine d'années
on quelqu'un qui a le sida ne meurt plus
du sida il vit avec le sida mais il doit
évidemment être accompagné quelqu'un qui
a un cancer peut vivre avec le cancer
des rémission la maladie avec des années
le le le diabète et puis les personnes
âgées à l'évidence qui souffr de
polypathologie euh sont directement
concernés donc nous devons définir des
financements qui permettent de prendre
en compte ces parcours de soins en ville
et à l'hôpital et à l'hôpital ça nous
amène à engager la réforme de la
tarification à l'activité qui euh euh ne
nous paraît pas totalement adapté dans
trois directions d'une part nous allons
tenir mieux compte de la situation des
établissements isolés pour euh le
financement de ces de ces des hôpitaux
d'autre part nous allons expérimenter le
financement par
parcours à l'hôpital autour d'une
pathologie qui est l'insuffisance rénale
chronique c'est une expérimentation
pouvoir comment nous pouvons faire et
puis troisième critère celui du volume
d'acte pour dissuader la course à
l'activité qu'on a constaté dans
certains établissement et donc dans
certaines circonstances il y aura des
tarifs dégressifs
le deuxème objectif donc mise en place
de
financement lié à une réorganisation de
notre offre de soins autour de la
valorisation de la médecine de premier
recours et d'une meilleure adaptation de
l'hôpital à la prise en charge des
parcours de santé deuxième objectif
c'est la volonté de faire reculer les
inégalités de santé à travers la
généralisation de la complémentaire
santé de mesures importantes d'une part
la simplification du recours à l'aide à
la complémentaire santé à
travers la disons des mesures qui vont
faciliter le recours à cette aide je
pense en particulier aux étudiants
isolés qui pourront accéder plus
simplement à la à la CMUC et à au
lancement d'appel d'offre pour
identifier de bons contrat de
complémentaire santé pour les personnes
qui peuvent bénéficier de l'aide à la
complémentaire santé par ailleurs
au-delà de cette aide à la
complémentaire santé nous avons la
volonté de mieux encadrer les contrats
complémentaires à travers la définition
de critères plus exigeants pour ce qu'on
appelle les les contrats responsables et
solidaires ce qui doit permettre de
définir un niveau minimum de prise en
charge complémentaire par exemple à
l'hôpital ce qui n'est pas aujourd'hui
obligatoire et à l'inverse d'un niveau
maximal de prise en charge pour éviter
des dérives inflationnistes solvabilisé
par les contrats complémentaires en gros
si un contrat complémentaire rembourse
les dépassements d'honorair sans aucune
limite on voit pas pourquoi des médecins
ne diraient pas à leurs patients bah
écoutez voilà quel est votre
complémentaire combien il vous rembourse
et et c'est c'est un et je solvabilise
et on sait que c'est ce qui se passe par
exemple pour les lunettes c'est
extrêmement clair le
troisème axe de ce PLFSS santé c'est une
politique de santé publique et de
régulation du médicament réaffirmé en
matière de santé publique deux thèmes
qui sont des thèmes constants dans mon
action la lutte contre le tabagisme et
la facilitation de l'accès à la
contraception en particulier pour les
mineurs et puis pour ce qui est de la
régulation du médicament nous mettons
nous nous maintenons une politique de
d'encadrement et de
régulation je veux rappeler que nous
sommes un pays qui continue de consommer
plus de médicaments que nos pays voisin
et donc c'est dans cet esprit que il
s'agit à la fois de poursuivre le
développement des médicaments générique
de faire baisser le prix des médicaments
génériques et puis
de d'encourager de nouveaux
comportements de la part de nos
concitoyens et c'est dans cet esprit-là
que sera expérimenté euh la dispensation
à l'unité des médicaments c'est donc un
PLFSS qui s'inscrit dans une politique
de
redressement assumer des comptes qui ne
sacrifie rien de notre pacte social
parce que je veux le redire aucun des
remboursements nouveaux aucune franchise
aucune contribution de la part des
assurés en matière de santé les
économies résultent véritablement de
réorientation ou de restr
structuration c'est un PLFSS qui vient
inscrire une refonte de nos politique
sociale retraite politique familiale
comme je les ai indiqué et qui mise en
œuvre de la politique de santé autour de
la stratégie nationale de santé et qui
amorce je l'ai dit avant l'arrivée de
Michel delonet la loi d'orientation
enfin qui envoie les signaux sur la loi
d'orientation de d'adaptation de la
société au au VI issement et puis c'est
un PLFSS qui vise évidemment à renforcer
l'équité de notre système
solidaire très bien merci madame la
ministre je salue donc l'arrivée de de
nos deux ministres madame bertinoti
madame de l'UNET j'avais annoncé votre
venue donc nous vous accueillons avec
plaisir et je vais peut-être vous
laisser la parole un instant avant de
donner la parole au rapporteur pour des
questions complémentaires donc madame
delonet si vous voulez bien et ensuite
madame
bertinoti le
PLFSS pardon excusez-moi pour le P sur
le PLFSS dans le secteur médico-social
en faveur des personnes âgées il y a eu
là aussi des choix et des efforts qui
sont tournés vers la
consolidation des politiques engagées le
taux de progression de l'ONDAM
médico-social est de 3 % l'ondame
général est comme on vient de de
l'exprimer étant de
2,4 %. l'ONDAM médico-social contribue
donc fortement à l'effort demander à
tous dans la mesure où pourtant les
besoins demeurent très dynamiques c'est
pour maintenir un niveau de dépenses
suffisante qui est réalisé un prélè sur
les réserves de la CNSA qui sont mises à
contribution à hauteur de
70 millions d'euros euh pour maintenir
donc cette AAM au total le niveau des
dépenses autorisé pour le secteur
personnes âgé en
2014 sera de
8,6 million
d'euros EUR sur un total sur un endam
total de
17,6 pour les établissements et services
cela va se traduire par un taux de
reconduction des budgets en augmentation
de 1 % alors qu'il est c'est-à-dire
1,1 % sur la masse salarielle et
0,55 % sur les prix cette cette ce taux
de reconduction permet de maintenir et
de couvrir les effets des gvt ou le
financement des mesures
catégorielles en ce qui concerne la
politique de médicalisation il lui est
consacré
140 millions d'euros dont 100 dont 10
pour la réouverture partielle du tarif
global cette réouverture parti
permettra une solution de d'urgence
enfin de compensation euh pour euh les
euh les établissements en convergence
pour certains établissements en
convergence tarifaire vous le savez
aussi un rapport récent le démontre que
le tarif global permette en parallèle
des économies sur le sur la contribution
de la sécurité sociale
enfin comme s était engagé le président
de la République le plan Alzheimer est
poursuivi et l'on évite euh lesffet de
rupture sur les mesures arrivées à
esséan